Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Zülal Solak
(Alkış)
Merhabalar.
İhtiyaç Haritası, yaklaşık bir
buçuk yılı tamamlamış oldu şimdi.
Ve biz ilk Koç'tan arkadaşlarımızla da
böyle bir araya gelip üzerine çok
çalışma yapmış ve konuşmuştuk.
Şimdi tekrar bugün burada sizlerle
anlatıyor olmak İhtiyaç Haritasını,
sizlerle yeniden buluşuyor olmak,
bizler için çok değerli aslında
İhtiyaç Haritası ekibi olarak.
Hep beraber gelmek istedik
buraya ama, çok çeşitli illerde
çeşitli faaliyetler yürütüyoruz.
Tam da İhtiyaç Haritası sebebiyle.
Aranızda İhtiyaç Haritasını
kısmen duymuş olanlar vardır belki.
Çalışma yürütmüş olduklarımız
bile olabilir, bilmiyorum.
Ama bu beta versiyonuydu,
şimdiye kadar olan versiyon.
Ben en baştan size anlatmak
istiyorum aslında İhtiyaç Haritasını.
Biz İhtiyaç Haritasına
neden ihtiyaç duyduk aslında,
biz; Ali Erdem Özgür, Güler Altınsoy,
Elif Kalan ve ben, aslında dördümüz
İhtiyaç Haritasını başlangıçta
kurmak için yola çıktık.
İhtiyaç Haritası biraz bizim
ihtiyacımızdı aslında.
Hani, ihtiyaç olmadan kurulan ya da
ihtiyaç olmadan yola çıkılan faaliyetler,
işte ne bileyim,
şirket kuruluşları bile aslında,
hiçbir zaman çok başarılı olamıyor.
Neden İhtiyaç Haritası bizim ihtiyacımızdı
ve biz niye bir ihtiyaçtan
aslında hareketle çıktık yola?
Şöyle ki ben, sivil toplumda
13 yaşımdan beri çalışıyordum.
İşte Halk Evi geçmişim vardı,
Halk Evinden dolayı
çeşitli illerde, mahallelerde
en küçük ölçekten en büyük
ölçeğe kadar çok çeşitli çalışmaların
içinde bulunmuştum.
Bundan dolayı, sadece
Halk Evleriyle başlayan o süreç,
onunla sınırlı kalmadı.
Ondan sonraki süreçte böyle,
herhalde bir otuza yakın dernekte
çeşitli faaliyetler yürüttüm.
Yaklaşık bir 4-5 tanenin
kuruluş aşamasında bulundum.
Ve bilfiil çalışmaya başladım.
Bu çalışma isteği, benim tabii
günümün tamamını doldurmaya başladı.
Biraz oyunculuk kariyeri ile birleşince de
daha fazla sivil toplum örgütü ile
çalışma zorunluluğu artık olmaya başladı.
Ve ben şunu düşündüm, dedim ki
ya acaba nasıl her yere yetişebilirim,
ya da her yerde nasıl bir şekilde
faaliyette bulunmak istediğim,
çalışmak istediğim derneklerle
nasıl bir şekilde ilişkiye girebilirim,
onların faaliyetlerini nasıl
sürdürülebilir kılabilirim,
onun için nasıl bir
fayda sağlayabilirim derken,
bu İhtiyaç Haritası fikri yavaş
yavaş aslında çıkmaya başladı.
Ve bir tarafından da,
tabii hani hem oyunculuk yapıyorum,
hem işte dizi film bir
yandan tiyatro falan derken,
zaman gittikçe daralıyordu ve zamanı
doğru kullanmak nasıl olacak,
gerçek ihtiyaç sahibine ulaşmak nasıl
olacak, bunun için ne yapmak lazım
ve bunun güvenilirliliğini
sağlamak nasıl olacak yani
destekçinin de güvenilir birisi olması
lazım, ihtiyaç sahibinin de aynı şekilde.
Gerçek ihtiyaç sahibine
ulaşmak nasıl olacak?
Bütün bunlara, sorulara aslında
böyle kafamda şekillenmeye başlayınca,
bir ihtiyaç listesi çıktı aslında, ilk
başta bu bir harita değildi benim için.
Ve ihtiyaç listesini Elif'e
anlatmaya başladım,
Elif'le de Habitat Derneğinden daha önce
siyasetçilerin yaşlarını küçültmek,
gençleri siyasete aslında atılmalarını
sağlamak için bir
çalışma yürütüyorduk Elif'le.
Derken o çalışmanın ilerleyen safhasında,
ben Elif'e bunu anlattım;
İhtiyaç Haritası'nın
ihtiyaç listesi kısmını.
Sonra o bana dedi ki; bak Ali Ercan var,
Ali Ercan'la birlikte biz aslında
bir şey yapabiliriz, Ali Ercan da
harita bazlı çalışmalar yapıyor.
İşte, seçim haritası çalıştığı vesaire,
onun da böyle bir ihtiyaç fikri var.
Biz derken o ihtiyaç listesi ile,
İhtiyaç Haritasını birleştirdik aslında.
Yani daha doğrusu harita kısmını
birleştirdik, İhtiyaç Haritası oldu.
Yaklaşık bir yıldır, yani bir yıl
süren bir çalışmaydı aslında,
[Yedi milyar dört yüz otuz iki milyon
altı yüz altmış üç bin iki yüz yetmiş beş]
Evet.
[Dünya Nüfusu artışta] Buralarını
biraz anlatmış oldum aslında size.
Sunum üzerinden gitmek,
benim için çok böyle keyifli olmuyor.
Ve hep şurdan yola çıktık aslında
bu 1-1,5 yıllık çalışmanın içinde;
bunun öncesinde daha doğrusu
sizlerin önüne çıkmadan önce
bir iki yılı daha var
ve bu iki yılın içinde
hep altyapı çalışması yaptık.
Hep şunu aradık aslında yani, biz
sadece bir bağışla mı ilerliyoruz acaba?
Hani, bütün sivil toplum örgütleri gibi,
o sivil toplum örgütleri için çeşitli
faaliyetler yapacağız, işte ne bileyim,
takvim çıkartacağız ve o yılın
takvimini insanlarla paylaşacağız;
ne bileyim, konser yapacağız o konserin,
yani bunun için de mi kaynak yaratmalıyız,
yoksa sivil toplumun gücüne mi
inanmalıyız noktasından hareketle,
hep böyle bir beta versiyon hedefledik,
o beta versiyonun içinde de hep,
şey dedik hani, beta kültürü oraya
mümkün mertebe sadık kalalım,
ama bir taraftan da, şunu da yapalım;
insanların katkılarıyla gelişen
bir yapının, gerçekten hani tam bir beta
kültürü olsun ve o katkıları ile gelişen
bir yapının içinde, onlara da
sorumluluklar yükleyelim.
Bu anlamda, gönüllülerimize çok
önem verdik ve bizimle birlikte
çalışma yürütmek isteyen, bizimle birlikte
teknolojik altyapıda katkı sağlamak
isteyenleri de aramıza kattık.
Biz İhtiyaç Haritasında neyi paylaşıyoruz,
üzerinden aslında birazcık da gitmek için
burada dümeni kırıyorum.
Ve buradan hareketle aslında,
yurt dışındaki birçok Türk,
Türk kökenli arkadaşımıza ulaştık.
Daha doğrusu, onlar bize ulaştılar.
Derken böyle gerçekten
ailemiz çok büyümeye başladı.
Şimdi İhtiyaç Haritasının yeni versiyonu
çıkıyor ve yeni versiyonunun içinde
yaklaşık bir on kişi,
bu altyapı çalışmasının tamamını
yurt dışından yürütüyorlar aslında.
İşte kimi Facebook'ta çalışıyor,
kimi Twitter'da çalışıyor,
kimi Silikon Vadisi'nde
bambaşka bir proje geliştirmenin,
bir RV çalışmasının içinde
ekibiyle birlikte var oluyor.
Kimi Hollywood'da işte ne bileyim,
çok ciddi bir şirkette,
teaser ve fragman kesiyor.
Yani dolayısıyla böyle, ekip gittikçe
genişledi ve biraz daha profesyonelleşti
ve bu süreçte, tam da İhtiyaç Haritasının
ruhuna uygun bir şey olmuş oldu aslında.
Çünkü biz kâr amacı gütmeyen,
ekonomisini kendi kendine var eden,
neredeyse hiçbir yerden desteklenmeyen,
tamamen kurucuların
finanse ettiği bir yapıyız
ve bunun sürdürülebilir kılınması için de,
iki yıllık vizyonumuzu,
iki yıllık aslında yapacağımız durumu
maddi kaynağı da yarattık ve planladık.
Nasıl yarattık, bunu aslında
yine kısaca anlatayım size.
Bizler fonluyoruz.
O fonun içinde, işte tek tek
isimlerini saymayayım tekrardan;
Ali Ercan'ın, Elif'in, benim, Güler'in ve
artık bize eklenen dört arkadaşımızın da
katkıları var.
Ve o katkı ile ilerliyoruz.
Şimdi yeni versiyonda, bizimle birlikte
çalışacak dört ayrı şirket daha olacak
ve bu şirketlerle
ilerliyor olacağız aslında.
Hiçbir zaman, bir yerin markasını
ya da işte ne denir, stratejisini güdüyor
ya da onu promote ediyor olmuyoruz zaten.
Bundan dolayı da,
yine işte o sivil toplum ruhuna,
her daim sadık kalacağımızı
işte kendimize düstur ediniyoruz.
Ve bundan dolayı da aslında hiçbir
sponsoru ya da bize destek olmayan,
maddi anlamda destek olmak
isteyenleri işin içine dahil etmiyoruz.
Biraz yine İhtiyaç Haritası
tarafına dönecek olursak,
işte evet, bu ihtiyaçtan
yola çıkarak şunu yaptık:
dedik ki bir ihtiyaç sahibi
ve bir destekçi, bizim derdimiz o zaten,
onları buluşturmak ve buluşma noktası
olarak da direkt ihtiyaç haritasının
üzerinden başladı durum.
Destekçiyi giriyoruz,
mesela diyelim ki bir yerde
bir şeye destek vermek istiyoruz.
Bir kütüphanenin kurulumuna
destek vermek istiyoruz.
O ihtiyacı görüyoruz.
Sonra o ihtiyacı destekçi
olarak girip diyoruz ki,
ben bu ihtiyacı karşılamak istiyorum.
Oraya üye olduktan sonra,
İhtiyaç Haritasına üye olduktan sonra
ve bizim arkadaşlarımız da aslında,
sizlerle iletişime geçip
o ihtiyacı karşılamanız noktasında,
bir bağlayıcı oluyorlar aslında,
bir bağlantı noktası oluyorlar.
İhtiyaç girerken de aslında aynı yolu
izliyoruz, yani diyelim ki işte
biz Siirt'te bir kütüphane kurmak
istiyoruz, bir okulun öğretmeniyiz.
Kendi bilgilerimizi giriyoruz ilk önce.
Nasıl bir okul, neredeyiz.
Orayı pin'liyoruz,
orayı pin'ledikten sonra da,
direkt işte bu ihtiyacı giriyoruz.
Bizim için ihtiyacın
ne kadar ayrıntılı girilirse,
o kadar hızlı geri dönmesi
aslında kolaylaşıyor.
Bu noktada işte biraz durumu
matematikleştirmeye çalışıyoruz,
çünkü aslında bizim işimizi
en çok yavaşlatan şey,
detaylı ihtiyacın girilmemesi
ve bizim aslında sürekli ihtiyaç
sahibini ya da destekçiyi arıyor olmamız.
Sistem aslında bu kadar basit yani
aslında basit işleyen bir yapısı var.
Bu anlamda, bu şimdi arkaya yansıyan ekip
ilk önce bizim Güler, Ali, ben ve Elif'ten
oluşurken, sonra Gujan ve Hazal
İlksen eklendi bizim gruba.
Ve gittikçe de büyüyor.
Arkamda gördüğünüz
ekip yine Semiha ve Yağmur,
bizim sürekli, bilfiil çalışan
maaşlı arkadaşlarımız.
Onun dışında onlarla birlikte
her gün aslında İhtiyaç Haritasını
hayata geçiren 20 kişi daha var,
toplamda 22 kişiler aslında.
Onlar daha gönüllülük
esasıyla çalışan insanlar.
Fakat işte her zaman böyle sistemin
doğru bir şekilde işlemesi için,
iki kişinin her daim aslında İhtiyaç
Haritasının, ihtiyacharitasi.org'un,
ihtiyaç sahibi ve destekçinin sorularını
cevaplayacak bir yerde durması gerekiyor.
Bunun yanı sıra,
biz teknik destek de alıyoruz,
mesela bir çağrı merkezi desteğimiz var.
O da çağrı merkezi çalışanlarını eğitip
o çağrı merkezinden bir şekilde,
birlikte İhtiyaç Haritası üzerine
bize destek vermelerini sağlıyoruz.
Aslında birçok şirketle, birçok kurumla
bilfiil çalışabilecek durumdayız,
öyle bir altyapımız var
ve aslında öyle de oluyor.
Kimi zaman valilikle, kaymakamlıkla;
kimi zaman belediyelerle, muhtarlarla,
sivil toplum örgütleriyle, 200'e yakın
sivil toplum örgütüyle
çalıştı İhtiyaç Haritası.
Sürekli entegre bir biçimde çalışıyoruz.
Bizim için aslolan aslında,
gerçek ihtiyaç sahibine ulaşmak.
Bunu anlamak için de biraz
araştırma yapmamız gerekiyor.
Bunu nasıl yapıyoruz?
Mahallelerde, illerde, tek tek aslında,
mahalle düzeyine kadar inecek
gönüllülerimiz var.
Şu anda, 60,000'e yakın
gönüllümüz var aslında.
O 60,000 gönüllünün içinde,
aktif bir biçimde çalışan,
aşağı yukarı 20,000 kişi var.
Bu 40,000'i bir şekilde sadece
bizim hani kampanya olduğunda,
ya da herhangi bir
faaliyet yürüttüğümüzde,
o faaliyet için yönlendirdiğimiz kişiler
oluyor; kimi zaman TEGEV ile bir faaliyet
yürütüyoruz, o TEGEV'in faaliyetine
gönüllü olarak yönlendiriyoruz onları
mesela örnek olsun diye söylüyorum.
Diğer 20,000 kişi ile,
mümkün mertebe şunu yapabiliyoruz;
bu kişinin gerçekten ihtiyacı var mı,
lütfen işte Siirt'in şu ilçesine
gider misiniz ya da bunun için,
bizim için buna destek olabilir misiniz,
bu yönlendirmeyi yapıyoruz
aslında oradaki gönüllülerimize.
Tabii sadece bununla sınırlı kalmıyoruz,
muhtarlıklarla da, aynı şekilde
check ediyoruz, bakıyoruz;
valilikten de durumu ve kişiyi
anlamaya, kavramaya çalışıyoruz.
Bu arada kişinin bütün
bilgileri bizde oluyor aslında.
Şimdiye kadar sadece TC
kimlik numarasını eklemedik.
Bundan sonraki süreçte,
artık TC kimlik numarası da olacak.
Biraz şu İhtiyaç Haritasının
başlangıcına yine bir döneyim
ve yavaş yavaş oraya doğru toplayayım.
Biz aslında ilk 7 Ekim'de çıktık yola,
7 Ekim 2015'te bir zirvede aslında
UNDP'nin zirvesinde
ve niye orayı seçtik,
neden UNDP'nin zirvesi?
Çünkü sivil toplumdan birçok kuruluş vardı
ve onlarla birlikte
çalışmayı hedeflediğimiz için,
ya biz çatı olmak derdinde
değildik hiçbir zaman aslında,
biz hep bir bağlantı noktası olalım,
işte çatı olalım herkes bizim altımızda
toplansın, sivil topluma yepyeni bir soluk
getirelim, sadece biz konuşalım değil
tam tersine, biz hep diyelim ki
UNDP / İhtiyaç Haritası olalım veya
Koç Üniversitesi / İhtiyaç Haritası
olalım, bizim için aslolan, birleştirmek
ve aslında işi sivil toplumdaki
hiyerarşik düzeni bir şekilde
yok etmek belki de.
Bunun imkânsız olduğunu
biliyoruz her şey gibi.
Sivil toplumda da bir birbirleri
arasında sürekli bir rekabet var.
Benim için çok anlaşılmaz ama sivil toplum
için anlaşılabilir bir durum belki,
bilmiyorum.
Ama ben bu yardımlaşma ve imece
kültürüne inandığım için,
ben ve arkadaşlarım diyeyim,
bu online imeceden hareketle aslında,
o UNDP'nin zirvesine çıktık.
Ve o zirvedeki sunumdan sonra,
birçok sivil toplum örgütüyle aslında
böyle yan yana çalışmaya başladık.
Beklediğimizden çok
daha iyi tepkiler aldık.
Devamında yurtdışındaki birçok zirveye
aslında katılma şansı, imkânı bulduk.
Ve o zirvelerde konuşma şansımız oldu.
Ve yine Berlin'de, Avusturya'da,
şu anda Avustralya'da,
Washington'da çalışmalar başlattık.
Bunlardan en ciddi olanı, Güler Altınsoy,
ortaklarımızdan Güler Altınsoy'un
Washington'da yürüttüğü bir çalışmaydı.
Yine bir zirvede aslında tanıştığı
bir belediye başkanı aracılığıyla,
bizim İhtiyaç Haritasını
uygulamak istediler ve oraya da
Neighbour Good Maps dedik aslında.
Şimdi yurt dışı için de, Neighbour
Good Maps aslında çalışmaya başladı
ve 2017 sonuna doğru globalde de aslında
İhtiyaç Haritası bizimle birlikte olacak,
ama aslolan bizim için Türkiye'deki
teknolojiyi geliştirmekti.
Dediğim gibi işte hep
buluşma noktasına hareket ettik.
Bizim buradaki amacımız mahalle
düzeyine indirmekti aslıında hikâyeyi.
Evet, hani bir çeşit mahalle ekonomisine
dokunuyor, evet hani birçok açılımı var,
bizim için uzağı yakın ediyor falan,
ama bizim için aslolan;
mahallede neye ihtiyacımız olduğuydu,
hani derneklerin yürüttüğü
faaliyetlerden uzak açıdan bakıp
mahallenin içine girmeden, ithal bir
fikirle oraya bir şey entegre etmek
bizim galiba İhtiyaç Haritası felsefesine
en ters duruşlardan biriydi,
o yüzden derdimiz mahalleye yerleşmek,
mahalledeki durumu anlamak,
mahallelinin neye ihtiyacı olduğunu
kavramak ve oradan hareketle
bir şey üretmekti.
Sürdürülebilirliğin esası da
aslında bizim için buna dayanıyordu
ve bu felsefeyle hareket ettik.
Bu anlamda pilot mahalleler seçtik.
O mahallelerin içinde de
çalışmalar yürüttük.
Onların sonucunu da bir başka
konuşmamızda inşallah size aktaracağım,
çünkü hâlâ devam eden bir süreci var.
Fakat şunu söyleyebilirim, bundan başkası
zaten olamazmış; yani halk evi
veya köy enstitülerinin kurulması,
çok doğru bir okumaymış.
Bizler bunu çok iyi biliyorduk,
fakat hani bir tarafıyla da
tekrar yeniden bu çalışmaları
yapınca daha da iyi anladık ki,
sadece bir yardım toplayıp
kısa süreli bir yere göndermek,
çok kısa bir çözüm.
Bunun sürdürülebilirliliğini sağlamak,
o mahallede neyin gerçekten neye
ihtiyacı olduğunu anlamak,
kişilerin gelir düzeyini kavramak,
o gelir düzeyine göre göndereceğiniz
kitabı, göndereceğiniz ihtiyacı
bile belirlemek çok önemliymiş.
Daha çok yolumuz olduğunu
anladık bu anlamda.
Ama İhtiyaç Haritası ruhuna da
uygun bir çalışma yaptık,
bu arada bu sunumun dışında da
size küçükçe bunu anlatmış olayım.
Bu sosyal medyanın
gücü gerçekten inanılmaz.
Biz açtıktan, İhtiyaç Haritasını
faaliyete geçirdikten sonra,
önümüzdeki üç ay boyunca
sürekli çöktü o süre zarfında.
Çünkü çok büyük bir ilgi ile karşılaştık.
Devamında bu ilgiyi nasıl kontrol
edebiliriz, buna nasıl cevap verebilirizin
aslında yolunu aradık.
Ve altyapıyı güçlendirip,
server'ımızı güçlendirip
o ilgiye cevap vermeye
başladık yavaş yavaş.
Bize ne gibi ihtiyaçlar geliyor aslında;
en çok okul ihtiyaçları geliyor.
Neden okul ihtiyaçları geliyor,
çünkü biz aslında onu güvenli buluyoruz
ve onu onaylıyoruz.
Çünkü bir okul var, okulun yerini
biliyoruz, işte öğretmeni biliyoruz,
Milli Eğitim Bakanlığının altyapısıyla
işte internetten girip çok rahat
bulabiliyoruz o okulu.
O öğretmeni gerçekten bulabiliyoruz, bu
arada Milli Eğitim Bakanlığından aldığımız
bir yazı ve bir protokolümüz var;
tüm öğretmenleri ve öğrencileri ile
çalışabileceğimize dair bir belgemiz var.
Bu önemli bir belge,
özellikle bu sıralarda.
Yani dolayısıyla, birlikte çalışma
yürütebilmenin herhalde bir yolu
bizim için.
Buna benzer yine Ticaret Odası
ile yaptığımız, Ticaret Odaları ile
yaptığımız aslında bir faaliyet var.
O da Türkiye'nin %47'si sadece,
internete ulaşabiliyor.
İnternete ulaşamayan kişiler için
Ticaret Odasında İhtiyaç Masası kurduk
aslında şu anda.
Ve bu İhtiyaç Masasına gidip
kişiler ihtiyaçlarını
ya da desteklerini girebiliyorlar.
Okullardan gelen ihtiyaçlar dediğim gibi,
galiba beni en etkileyen ihtiyaç,
işte sokak hayvanları,
işte onların ihtiyaçları var;
aslında 12 başlığımız var,
bu başlığın içinde çeşitli ihtiyaçlar var,
her aya, bir aslında başlığımız var.
Bu başlıklar da nereden çıktı aslında,
yine Birleşmiş Milletler Kalkınma
Programının içinde,
17 hedefin içinde aslında,
biz bu 17 hedefi 12'ye indirip
bu başlıklar üzerinden ilerlemiş olduk.
Beni en çok etkileyen ihtiyaçlardan
biri dediğim aslında Diyarbakır'da bir
köy öğretmeninin girdiği ihtiyaç oldu.
Galiba bizim en hızlı giderilen
ihtiyaçlarımızdan da biriydi o.
Çünkü bizim İhtiyaç Haritasında çalışan
ekip bir anda böyle kendilerini tutamayıp
dışarı çıkıp bu ihtiyacı
hızla karşılayıp gönderdiler.
O da şöyleydi; bir köy öğretmeni şöyle
yazmış, demiş ki, ''Dünyanın sadece
Diyarbakır'dan ibaret olmadığını göstermek
için bir teleskopa ihtiyacım var.
Lütfen bize bir teleskop gönderin,''
diye bir ihtiyaç girmiş.
İlk önce bizim ekip tarafından,
sonrasında Türkiye çapında böyle bir
teleskop kampanyası başlatan
bir köy öğretmenimizdir aslında.
Ve Türkiye'nin çok çeşitli yerlerine,
teleskoplar gitti.
Gelinlik ihtiyacı mesela karşılandı.
Iphone 6 isteyen var.
(Kahkaha)
Iphone 7 isteyen var şimdi.
Playstation 4 alamıyorum çocuğuma,
çok mağdurum gibi ihtiyaçlar giriliyor.
Huzur isteyen var,
beyin isteyen var falan böyle.
Boşanmak için avukat
isteyen var falan böyle.
Ondan sonra, gerçekten çok acayip
istekler var, hepsini onaylamıyoruz
ama bununla ilgili böyle bir
arkadaşlarımız işte böyle bir
video hazırlamanın peşindeyiz
şu anda yapılan konuşmalarla.
Ambulans isteyen oldu mesela falan.
(Kahkaha)
Bayağı İhtiyaç Haritasını arayıp falan.
Bir tarafı çok eğlenceli ama, bir tarafı
da gerçekten insanın yüreğini çok böyle
burkan ve hani daha çok şey yapmanın
ihtiyacını her zaman böyle bir tarafta
tutan bir yapısı var İhtiyaç Haritasının,
yani bir yandan çok sevimli, evet tatlı;
ama bir yandan da çok acı
gerçeklerle sizi karşılaştırıyor.
Bu arada çok ilginç ihtiyaçlar da oluyor
ve biz hani şunu da sağlamaya çalışıyoruz,
ihtiyaç sahibinin kendisi girsin
ihtiyacını, biz kimsenin ihtiyacını
telefondan böyle alıp girmiyoruz.
Sadece böyle birkaç ulaşılamayacak
köy okulu için aslında,
gönüllü öğretmenlerimiz var,
onların aracılığıyla yapıyoruz.
Şimdi işte yaşlılar ve engelliler için
aslında aynı yöntemi izliyoruz.
Bunu daha kurgusal bir altyapıya getirip
burada da bir başlık açacağız.
Bu sıralamayı size anlattım aslında;
ihtiyaç gir, destek ol, editör onayı,
ihtiyacın yayınlanması ve buluşma.
Bu basit sistemin şimdi işte bizim için
ikinci versiyonu, kurumsal yapılarla
birlikte çalışabileceğimiz
bir düzeye getiriyor bizi.
Yani İhtiyaç Haritası aynı Facebook gibi,
Twitter gibi bir yapı olmasını çok büyük
bir hayal ediyoruz tabii ama, bizim için
çok uzak bir hayal olsa da,
bir tarafıyla şöyle bir
gerçek var gerçekten.
Artık şirketler, okullar, son geçtiğimiz
5 yılda aslında, çok dikkat ediyorlar
sivil toplumla ilgili çalışmalara.
Ve çalışanlarının, sivil toplumda
faaliyet yürütmesine çok önem veriyorlar,
çünkü bunun bir takım işi olduğunu,
topluluk için de çalışmanın ne kadar
önemli olduğunu,
farkındalığı nasıl
arttırdığını kavradıkları için,
lise düzeyinden, hatta orta okul
düzeyinden başlayıp iş hayatında da
devam eden birçok çalışma
ve faaliyet yürüyor.
Biz bu çalışmaların ve faaliyetlerin,
düzeyinin gittikçe arttığı
ve yine sürdürülebilirliğin esas olduğu,
okulun ihtiyacını karşıladık
ve bitti değil de, ya da ne bileyim
bir kişinin ihtiyacını karşıladık bitti
değil de işte o projeyi nasıl sürdürebilir
o kişiyi nasıl takip edebiliriz,
o ille ilgili, o gölle ilgili, o evle
ilgili nasıl bir çalışma yapıldıysa onun
devamı takibi nasıl olacak noktasından
hareketle bir şey yapmaya çalışıyoruz.
O yüzden de 5. sınıflarla da
çalışma yapıyoruz bu anlamda.
Sonrasıyla da çalışmalar yürütüyoruz.
Ve kurumsal hayatta da dediğim gibi,
bu versiyon, bizim için çok etkin
ve kolay bir çalışma sağlıyor,
çünkü aslında kurumlar arası ilişkiyi,
kişilerin kendi hesaplarını
yaratmasını sağlıyor.
Tabii kişilerin kendi hesaplarıyla
kurumsal hesaplarını birleştirebilme
imkanı sağlıyor.
Kurum içi çalışmalara aynı zamanda
imkan ve aslında böyle bir bir şekilde
uyum sağlıyor.
Ve bu anlamda, ikinci versiyonu da
çok yakın zamanda
sizlerle de buluşturacağız.
Aslında aşağı yukarı
sunumdaki her şeyi anlattım,
bu bizim için etkin çalışan
üyelerin rakamları.
Ve işte bir taraftan,
bu 60,000'e yaklaşan,
aslında bizim dediğim gibi,
sürekli yer değiştiren üyelerimiz ve hani
etkin bir biçimde bizimle faaliyet yürüten
aslında işte 30,000'e
yakın olan 26,000 rakamı.
Sürenin ne kadar kaldığını nereden
takip ediyoruz acaba, onu bilmiyorum.
Şu an göremiyorum.
Aa, bitmiş zaten.
Tamam, yavaş yavaş toparlayayım.
Bizim bu seneki versiyondaki
hedefimiz aslında,
yaklaşık 12 başlığa 24 gönüllünün olduğu
ve bunların da kanaat
önderlerinden olduğu bir yapı kurmak.
Ocak ayında,
yeni versiyonla bir şekilde yeniden
belki de diğer arkadaşlarımla birlikte,
karşınızda olmayı hedefliyoruz.
Dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)